quand le patrimoine de l'État se
volatilise des meubles des statuettes
des tableaux et c'est vrai que le bilan
dressé hier par nos confrères de
compléments d'enquête sur France 2 est
assis hallucinant notamment à l'Elysée
sur les 77370
œuvres prêtées par le Mobilier national
au palais présidentiel depuis 150 ans et
bien trois sur quatre sont aujourd'hui
introuvables principalement de la
vaisselle le responsable de la sécurité
de la DGSE qui nous dit utilisez un
smartphone quand on est un personnage
public qu'on a des responsabilités c'est
une faute
ça veut dire que nous devons alors tous
nous placer dans un niveau de vigilance
et et de d'alerte si j'ose dire qui est
supérieur à celui que nous pratiquons
aujourd'hui et sans doute et sans doute
j'ai le souvenir très précis d'un dîner
présidentiel qui était organisé à
Versailles et ou à la sortie à ma grande
stupéfaction il y avait un système de
contrôle vous étiez
de contrôle et ils ont retrouvé une
coûte petite cuillère
la manif c'est de gauche mais la manif
pour tous de droite ainsi on a décidé le
site créé par Théo de lemazure Doctor en
informatique de 23 ans pour s'amuser du
clivage droite-gauche avec tout et
n'importe quoi le football la bière et
le pain au chocolat sont de gauche quand
le rugby levain et la chocolatine sont
de droite parmi le million de requêtes
tapé par des internautes la plus
populaires c'était manuel Macron et n'en
déplaise au Président il est droite on
te demande souvent qu'est-ce que tu
penses de Monsieur Macron
[Rires]
ça peut m'arranger
qu'est-ce qui vous met en colère
on sent on sent évidemment que vous êtes
en train que vous avez un hémisphère qui
parle et l'autre qui se dit je suis pas
sûr que j'ai raison et non c'est pas ça
en tout cas alors en tout cas on vous
sent pas à l'aise dans ce que vous êtes
en train de dire
que je me dis là je suis en train de
flinguer ma carrière politique en fait
c'est ça que je me dis je
il existe deux manières d'être heureux
dans sa vie l'une de se faire passer
pour un idiot l'autre est de l'être
vraiment
merci
Édouard de Pau
quel chemin parc j'ai un gars de 50 ans
aujourd'hui tu sais 50 ans il y a un
côté un peu chic 51 je pense que c'est
nul
un truc j'aime beaucoup dire c'est que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le sourire c'est une connexion aux
autres on se connecte à la personne qui
est en face de nous et c'est quelque
chose d'assez vulnérable qui peut être
un peu difficile mais je sais que
pendant cette période où on a été
masquée il nous a terriblement manqué et
le fait de mettre un focus spécialement
aujourd'hui et même dans son quotidien
de sourire ça fait du bien au moral ça
fait du bien au corps moi ce qu'on vous
m'avez raconté comment les les mômes
étaient méchants
à côté hein je me suis retenu hyper
longtemps
j'ai un sanglier et un sanglier là je
peux rien faire j'ai un sanglier
d'accord
vous savez maintenant ce qu'il vous
reste à faire pour parsemer votre chemin
de ses éclats de bonheur imprévisible en
plus bonne nouvelle le sourire est
gratuit et aucune pénurie n'est à
prévoir
[Rires]
bravo
je ne vous vois pas je ne vous vois pas
on va reprendre pardon non on continue
[Musique]
on a trop à plusieurs mais on va régler
ça tout de suite c'est parti couplet on
peut on peut passer sur les nananas
alors
garou a tué plus d'une chatte alors
garou a tué on va dire la comment je
pourrais dire ça alors
à tuer le la petite chatte d'Hélène
[Rires]
viens chanter avec nous c'est pas la
bonne saison
mais qu'est-ce que c'est
ne cherche pas des colères inutiles sans
toi bien
et repenser à la petite phrase de
Prévert soit heureux ne serait-ce que
pour donner l'exemple c'est pas mal